I have a roommate anyone where my
roommates a roommate nation I live with
an 82 year old Asian American woman
Carol Wang do you guys know her she's an
old lady in Glendale California it's
true I live with this old lady I found
her on Craigslist she takes in soldiers
with post-traumatic stress disorder but
I showed her a tape and she was like
okay you can stay - you win the soldiers
the soldiers moved out thus now it's
just like me and Carol being roommates
it's really weird to live with an 82
year old woman that is not your
grandmother I don't love her
she doesn't love me we're just roommates
we've roommate issues and it feels
ridiculous to go into a room like Carol
maybe I'm crazy but are there three or
four puddings left in the snack pack to
have a pudding Carol to have a pudding
Carol I'm not made of pudding Carol you
gotta ask it's a 50/50 thing we're doing
I run errands with her she lets me stay
there for free that's like the deal some
of the urns are bad but some of them are
great we got our feet massaged last week
for an hour which is too long but what a
problem to have my foot massage is too
long I'll live that life I will I'm
never moving out
you guys drink so does she
she's a drinker I make her a cocktail
every night it's called the Carol it's
2/4 scotch and then you mix in another
2/4 scotch the full glass of scotch
if she drinks every night before
blueblood with tom selleck at 6:00
good show better show than I wanted to
admit I didn't want to like blue blood
Carol got me into it I come from a
broken home
my dad divorces fifth wife two months
ago now it's really rip the family to
shreds
Johanne won't be around anymore know
[Music]
who's gonna tan in the backyard
sometimes dad are you sure about this
are you sure about this Joanne useless
human being
there's a reason you're fit right no
metal 4/5 there's no metal 4/4 and
Doreen was chill she was cool
my fourth mom Doreen she gave me a
brother for four years Doreen that's
crazy I had a brother for four years now
he's just some guy named Matt that lives
wherever I don't even know if he's alive
that's why I want to get famous to find
my baby brother Matthew Matt if you're
somehow watching this find me on social
media I forgot your last name I don't
know when you're young you think it's
yours but it's not yours
they have a different one
McDonald's all-day breakfast and anal
sex were the same to me like wanted it
got it time I'm good I don't want that
it was gross McMuffin in the afternoon
was gross I always knew it would be but
I still wanted to try it like my whole
life that's a perfect analogy whether
you're eating a big muffin in the
afternoon or having anal sex if your eye
catches a mirror during either of those
activities
oh you're staring at a stranger that's
not you in that mirror that's someone
else you guys like impressions all right
Oh get out of here on this is an
impression you can do at home anyone can
do it this is a there's a former
Broadway theater play director that now
manages a Red Lobster in Irvine
California so used to be big-time
Broadway theater play director super big
in the business you know big productions
the recession happened or something and
moved to Irvine tried to start a nap
yikes you know didn't work someone else
had the idea first and yeah the best job
he could find after that was managing a
Red Lobster former Broadway theater play
director now manager of a Red Lobster
let's see what we can do
placemats everyone okay so that's that's
my time thank you guys very much
you